I know yours looks better so today's a
special day
got anything planned hey is it
what month is thank you
I think it's February February oh god
it's Valentine's Day
are you serious okay okay what do we
have planned huh oh we got Chili's
dinner in a movie after it she's got out
the romance okay up up okay up there
line item - run - what do we do last
Valentine's Day I was around the Super
Bowl hole yeah what a game we in the
Fokin oh um I got it I like a little
bubbly walk along the beach you know
what you want how much woman I think
it's time to go for romance
no we haven't even cover for anniversary
we can't he'll be torn apart no
everybody can take it we set the bar low
for reason sausage on slow you just got
that rate is it we're going polo romance
I didn't want to ruin surprise but uh
you know rose petals pulling that
baby-making mix I didn't fill up on that
wait are you talking about your mom you
know she's coming to town today right oh
yeah you thought it was Valentine's Day
I knew my mom's coming to town are they
talking about
is it closed wait we're gonna do when
mom gets here Chili's